Can you talk about your own specific experiences slash methods used with
integrating the shadow?
Yeah.
Well I can actually,
I think a tremendous amount of what you might regard as shadow integration,
which in the parlance of behavioral psychologists would be something like
assertiveness training,
right?
It's training and how to stand up for yourself and for your,
let's say for your better self,
which would be the self that you could use productively over a medium to long
period of time that would be of use to you,
but also views to people around you.
So it's a self that's owned by the necessity of taking care of yourself,
but also simultaneously taking care of the people around you.
MMM.
I think that the simplest way to start that work is to consult your resentment.
You know,
it's easy to become bitter about life and to become angry because of course life
is difficult and it's full of disappointments and
people are also subject to be trail on the part of themselves and on the part of
people that hypothetically care for them.
And so it's easy to get bitter and to be resentful and resentment is a very
useful emotion even though I think it's one of the most,
uh,
damaging emotions if it's not dealt with properly.
So if you're resentful basically means only one of two things,
it either means you should grow up and quit whining and get on with your life.
Or it means that you're being subject to tyrannical forces of one form or
another maybe emanating from you.
Maybe a consequence of the natural environment,
maybe a consequence of society.
You're being subjected to radical forces and you're not putting your own best
interests forward.
Like in that broader sense that I described.
And I don't mean you're selfish,
narrow interests that only serve the purposes of instantaneous gratification.
I mean your own best interest in terms of developing your character over the
span of your life.
If you're resentful,
it either means that you're immature and that you should grow the hell up.
And so you need to figure out how much of your resentment is,
is,
is that,
and maybe the allied with the desire to find other things or people to blame.
But the other possible option is that you have something to say or do,
right?
Because you're in a situation where you're violating your own internal ethical
standards and you're being required pressure,
let's say to say things you don't believe or to do things that you believe to be
wrong and you need to determine,
you need to start to strategize and plan how can rectify that so that you can
say what you mean.
Like if you're negotiating with a marital partner for example,
and there are issues in your marriage that aren't making you happy.
While the first thing is you have to take note of that,
right?
To see that you're actually unhappy.
Uh,
the second is that you have to be willing to engage in a certain amount of
conflict because in order to sort out what's disturbing you,
you're going to have to allay your concerns out on the table and say,
well look,
this is bothering me.
You don't have to say,
well,
I'm right and you're wrong and you have to fix this.
You have to say,
well,
I've noticed that this
pattern of interaction or lack of interactions say in our relationship is making
me resentful and angry,
and the danger of that,
of course,
as you're going to take it out on yourself and your partner,
the Dangerous Passion,
passive aggressiveness,
you know,
you're not going to respond to your partner positively when they do something
good,
if you're resentful about them and you're not going to respond to yourself
properly,
and so you have to lay it out on the table,
but sort of in a spirit of ignorance,
humility,
it's like,
look,
I'm frustrated.
I'm feeling this way about our relationship.
Here's what I think might be going wrong,
maybe on my part and maybe on your part and here's what I envision as a possible
solution.
That's also really necessary.
If you're going to say what you have to say,
which is to manifest yourself properly in the world,
is you can't just complain about what's wrong.
You have to think,
well,
what would my minimal preconditions for satisfaction B,
you have to offer that to the person that you're negotiating with.
And so then you learn to abide by the truth to the degree that you can do that
and no one does it perfectly,
you know?
But it,
it's very useful because you're not storing up a whole sequence of memories
about how you were unfairly treated and abused and betrayed.
Instead,
you're trying to stay on top of it and to note your unhappiness and
dissatisfaction when it manifests itself and to accept that that's the case.
And then to analyze that to see if it's your problem.
Like I said,
with regards to maturity or if it indicates that there's an injustice in the
manner in which you and the world are interacting and then to work to set that
right even in small ways.
And so it's,
it's a matter of character,
logical development and that makes you,
that makes you stronger over time.
And partly what you need,
you know,
in order to do that is you have to really understand,
and we do this,
this is why we built in the future authoring program.
We built the section where you have to outline your most dismal future,
right?
What your future would be like if you let all your bad habits and character,
logical weaknesses have the upper hand.
And the reason we did this is because you can't be a,
you can't straighten yourself out merely as a consequence of hope.
Let's say you lay out a vision for the future and you think about what your life
would be,
what you'd like your life to be like,
and then that makes you hopeful and it motivates you because it gives you
something worthwhile and higher order to work for.
Right?
And that's useful.
That's positive emotion working for you because positive emotion is experienced
in relationship to goals,
but it's not as not as useful as also being chased by something you're terrified
by.
And if you have a good sense of how you'd fall apart if you stayed week and just
exactly what kind of hell that would be.
Then when you determined to do something like to tell the truth and to say what
you think and to not do things that you hate,
then you're going to be pulled along by the purpose that your vision has
provided for you,
but also pushed along by your desire to avoid the worst forms of hell that
you've already outlined for yourself personally.
And that can also help you be brave enough to stand up in a situation that we
would require a conflict.
Because if you have something to say and you have something to negotiate about
with someone,
then there's going to be a certain amount of conflictual dialogue that
accompanies that right it to lay out a set of problems and to describe the fact
forthrightly that those problems characterize a relationship and then to seek
for solutions is quite stressful in the short term and it's really easy to
avoid.
And so people avoided all the time and then they store up grievances across the
span of the relationships and eventually the grievances mount to the point where
they return in monstrous form and just eat everything up.
That's where you get divorces or that's where you explode at your boss and ended
up fired or that's where you,
you know,
you develop high blood pressure over 15 years because he can't stand all the
accumulated,
uh,
Monse all the accumulated monsters in your closet and then you drink yourself
into oblivion because he can't stand your life.
That's all,
you know,
very counterproductive.
But it's easy to avoid that necessary conflict on a moment to moment basis
because it's very stressful to speak forthrightly about genuine conflicts.
Especially when you're dealing with important parts of your life,
but otherwise you don't straighten them out.
And then you have to carry all that forward.
So you need to be terrified of the consequences of not speaking your piece.
And that can counterbalance the terror of actually trying to have a
conversation.
So.